[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on analytical
validation of a next generation
sequencing laboratory developed test by
john williamson and rafael ramirez
i'm ben halen of thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be moderating
today's event
before we begin i'd like to encourage
you to engage with us
you can submit as many questions as you
want at any time during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box on the left and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
please welcome john and raphael
all right thanks ben for the
introduction
today we're going to focus on as ben
mentioned analytical validation of next
generation sequencing panel so the
agenda for today is that we're going to
start with a little bit of background
information
what is clia and cap and why new york
state is important to understand in the
analytical validation process we'll then
go into a little bit more detail
with an overview of the college of
american pathologist guidelines around
analytical validation that can be found
in their molecular pathology checklist
we'll then go into further detail
around some of those new york state
level guidelines for validations and
specifically review a few of the
revisions that just happened this year
in 2021
then we'll run through
actual analytical validation data set
from some of our previous
av work with with our customers and show
exactly how we go through some of these
analyses for a validation and then
finally we'll
give an overview of our analytical
validation services that we have
available from thermo fisher scientific
many of our ngs customers who are
onboarding new assays fall under three
main regulatory frameworks
generally all of them are
clia labs mainly for our us-based
customers and clea stands for clinical
laboratory improvement amendments which
were established in 1988 by the u.s
congress
it's actually run by the clinical
laboratory improvement and quality
division of cms or the centers for
medicaid and medic medicare services
and uh you know importantly for that
organizations with requirements that are
stricter than clia in the us can
actually conduct accreditation on behalf
of clia
and so you know flowing into that a good
number of our laboratories that we work
with are cap accredited labs
cap stands for the college of american
pathologists
it's a professional society consisting
of a group of board certified
pathologists and and they focus on
advocacy publication learning and you
know laboratory improvement processes
and they have a number of uh checklist
items that actually provide you know
regulate regulations and guidelines that
labs need to adhere to as they're
undergoing their analytical validation
process and they get pretty prescriptive
as well and technical so it's really
important that for a cap accredited lab
you you review those guidelines and
we'll go into some detail around them in
subsequent slides but but they really do
inform your validation design
and then layered on top of that for a
subset of our labs our new york state
department of health guidelines
so
the new york state department of health
actually has specific uh guidelines
around validation and regulation of next
generation sequencing uh panels and the
nice thing
in my opinion about the new york state
guidelines is that they have clear and
defined requirements
that labs need to adhere to when
validating next generation sequencing
somatic oncology
panels
the other thing that's important about
new york state
uh is that they're actually a third
party reviewer and a pathway to the
fda's 510 k approval pathway so it's uh
pretty important that labs understand
that new york state is a big player
especially in the u.s landscape around
av strategy and next generation
sequencing panels
but it's also important to understand
that their av guidelines and their av
approaches they scale globally as well
they have some really nice practices
around av design that we're going to get
to actually in some of the next slides
so moving now into
what an analytical validation would look
like for each of these agencies that
i've talked about in the last slide
this slide breaks down those av
components that a lab needs to address
during validation and onboarding of a
new test
so as you can see here each agency has
slightly different requirements but
through strategic av experimental design
a lab can satisfy all three agency
requirements in just a single validation
hey john i wanted to add here quickly um
one thing that that it highlights is
that um all these different guidelines
uh they're very similar um into the
metrics that they that they follow um
and that's something that we can use to
extrapolate and when we look at the
various regions um the stringency will
vary um but what we look for um will be
very very similar so uh that really
allow us to to look at this more from a
global perspective
even though we have this
very
defined uh guidelines that apply
mostly for north america but again those
similarities that we can extrapolate
across the globe
that's a great point thanks for pointing
that out raphael yeah so in the next few
slides i'll review some of these av
guidelines in detail using that cat
molecular checklist that i referred to
earlier as well as the new york state
department of health guidelines and then
we'll jump into some examples of each
experiment that are listed on this slide
from our past ngs av engagements just to
give a little bit of a flavor of how
some of these items can be addressed in
your ngs panel validation
so jumping straight into the cap
guidelines for analytical validation of
next generation sequencing panels
these first two guidelines address
accuracy and precision and
reproducibility so so this slide
actually pulls language directly from
those cap checklists so the first one
listed on this slide is accuracy and so
what they say is that the results of
each validation study includes
sufficient numbers of characterized
samples to provide a high degree of
assurance of the test accuracy so
in real terms or practical terms what
does that mean what it means is that you
need to run enough samples of the
intended type so if your test is a solid
tumor panel
and you're going to be running it on
fspe samples you want to have a good
number of ffpe samples run them through
your panel evaluate the variants that
you detect and compare them to
some orthogonal methodology
and there's two main classes of tests
that cap addressed here they're
qualitative tests and quantitative tests
so qualitative is a comparison of your
variant level results to
you know comparative orthogonal tests so
it can be an orthogonal ngs test or an
orthogonal pcr-based test that uses
sanger sequencing
the the second
bin of assays that fall into this
guideline are quantitative tests and
that's where you would take your results
and evaluate the
closeness of your quantitative result to
that of an orthogonal methodology or
this closeness to true um
metric that's listed here and in terms
of the number of samples it says
sufficient numbers it's a little bit
vague in that sense
that is generally at the discretion of
the laboratory director
though generally more is always better i
think we all want to run as many samples
as we possibly can through an analytical
validation
that being said there's a
cap and amp joint consensus guidelines
that came out a couple years ago
and in that paper they do a statistical
analysis and a sort of a power analysis
and they come up with a number of 59
samples to include in your accuracy
studies and so that's always you know
where we we start out with if we can
source 59 samples for an accuracy study
we're in really good shape
um a lot of our labs that being said do
a little bit fewer samples than that
because samples can be hard to come by
and you know that's a totally valid
strategy as well
the second item on this slide is the
precision and the reproducibility study
and
the language from cap is that the
results of each validation study include
sufficient number of samples with
repeated analyses to provide a high
degree of assurance of the test
precision and reproducibility
so what that means is if you have an
ffpe sample and you run it over and over
again you want to make sure you're
getting the same variant level results
and that the sample's passing qc and all
those basic metrics that you have and
generally we do that you know by running
a positive sample three times within a
run and then three times across three
different runs
and if the lab that we're working with
has multiple operators that are
performing the testing we try to vary
the who's preparing the test as well
because we really do want to ensure that
all of the variables that might come up
in a routine testing environment we try
to address those during the analytical
validation process
so the next cap guidelines that are
relevant for an analytical validation
are the reportable range and qualitative
cut off validation
so the reportable range
you know the language around caps says
that the results of each validation
study include sufficient numbers of
samples to confirm or establish the test
reportable range
and so you really want your
av sample set whenever possible to
encompass the full range of reported
values so that might mean a number you
know variance in the number of different
genes that are on your panel as well as
variants that span
allelic fraction or copy number or msi
status depending on the nature of the
panel that you are
validating you really want to have as
wide a variety of a sample set for your
validation as possible
qualitative tests when possible should
include all reportable outcomes so if
it's a pretty small panel uh like a
single gene or a single codon
then you know try to get as many
variant level results as possible and
then for the larger panels that becomes
considerably more challenging and and
most of the time i see labs take a
representative approach it's not
possible to have a sample that's
positive for every mutation that's
detected by your panel so you try to do
the best that you can
especially for rare variants those kinds
of samples can be somewhat challenging
to source and and that's where
control materials can can play an
important role in supplementing these
types of data sets
so secondary to that on this slide is
this qualitative cut off validation
so this one is for quality
that you use sort of a cut off value to
distinguish positive from negative you
want to
you know establish that cut off value
using that sufficient number of samples
again so usually we we kind of evaluate
this during the course of the validation
and then
translate that over
you know in the sop once that validation
is done and so an example of of this
would be
on some of the new you know larger ngs
panels you can actually get
microsatellite instability
data off of those panels or msi data and
generally that has a cutoff where if the
msi score is below a certain value it's
considered microsatellite stable and if
it's above a certain value it's
considered you know msi high or unstable
and so for for that at the example you
would want to in your av data set run
samples that are
mss or micro satellite stable and then
run samples that are msi high through
the panel evaluate that msi score and
compare it to your orthogonal msi result
and you know verify and establish a
cutoff in that fashion using a sample
set with orthogonal characterization
so continuing on through these
guidelines then the next two are
reference interval or reference range
and then uh important one the analytical
sensitivity and lower limit of detection
so on the left here the reference range
is actually the range of normal values
um it's not just the reference human
genome though uh it's actually the
variants that are
detected that are either considered
benign or pathogenic so it comes down a
little bit to variant level
interpretation and how you classify your
variant so it's important that you have
a policy in place
to define what types of variant that
you're going to be reporting how are you
classifying variants pathogenic versus
non-pathogenic
and uh you know what's that strategy
going to be post av for for variants
that you detect using your panel are you
going to report everything that you
detect are you going to do some sort of
filtering of the variants and only
report putative pathogenic variants or
or what have you and so you want to have
you know some evidence of that in your
in your av
um plan and your av summary as well
the second item on here is that
analytical sensitivity and lower limit
of detection
so
what that is is you want to for every
variant type targeted by the assay so
for snvs or single nucleotide variants
indels insertions deletions
cmvs you know copy number gains or
losses and fusions are generally the
main categories of ngs panels although
now we're
starting to see some of the msi or tumor
mutation burden tmb uh start to come
into play a little bit
what you want to do there is evaluate
and establish that analytical
sensitivity of the panel for each of
those variant classes so for snbs and
indels that's generally around the
allelic fraction the lowest allele
frequency of a variant that you can
detect and that's going to be really
driven by the
application that you're validating for
so like if you were doing solid tumor
mutational analysis
uh you know something like a four to
five percent other like fraction is is
generally what people um you know are
validating towards whereas if you're
doing a liquid biopsy application or
looking at
minimal residual disease research
applications then you would want to you
know evaluate the analytical sensitivity
down to a little bit lower of an allelic
fraction somewhere around you know that
0.5
percent allelic fraction or even down to
0.25
so really the analytical sensitivity
is experimentally
evaluated but you want to design those
experiments around how you're actually
going to be using the panel
moving forward so what's the intended
use of the panel in your lab
so
controls can actually be pretty helpful
in this regard
um the reason that controls are useful
is that they enable you to
get a larger cohort or span of variance
and variant types to be included in your
sensitivity studies
um so you know
for example our av service we actually
have a custom control for oncology
applications that we've put together and
i'll show some data from that control in
a later slide but but we put that
control together specifically to harbor
some really key variants that a lot of
labs are looking for they span variant
classes so it has smvs it has indels we
have
these and control as well as fusions and
then we actually have those at different
allelic frequencies or copy numbers and
and then we're able to have labs run
those controls through and actually
evaluate limits of detection using those
controls
so very important experiments um those
analytical sensitivity and lower limits
of detection and one that uh you know
you you certainly want to have driven by
how you plan to use that test
so continuing on through these cap
guidelines
analytical specificity and interfering
substances so you'll want to have enough
samples in your av
to establish the test specificity so
what that really means uh is you want to
run sufficient numbers of your intended
sample types so if you're looking at a
solid tumor panel and you're validating
a solid tumor panel and you find that
and you plan to run mainly ffpe samples
then of course you want to run ffte
samples through your analytical
validation and ensure you're getting
good assay performance in that sample
type if you're looking at a myeloid
application you would then you know
you'd want to include blood or bone
marrow sample collected in the types of
tubes that that you'll be using moving
forward if it's edta or if it's a liquid
biopsy
application and you want to use like a
strecture or something like that you
want to include you know all of those
pre-analytical variables in your
analytical validation to demonstrate
that your assay works end-to-end with
the
framework you're putting in place to
actually offer that test
some other common examples that we see
are evaluating the effect of melanin
content from
ffpe solid tumor samples
on assay performance it's known that
that can inhibit inhibit some downstream
applications so if you have those
samples available they're very good to
include and then also necrosis necrosis
so
you know necrotic samples have very very
degraded dna so if you can quantitate
that by you know upstream pathologist
assessment you can include some
samples with varying levels of necrosis
and try to dial in at what level of
necrosis can we still achieve successful
sequencing results and at what level of
necrosis maybe
do we not you know consider that sample
a candidate for for sequencing
and then a second on this slide are
clinical performance characteristics so
here is the clinical performance
characteristics of each assay are
determined and recorded using either
literature citations or a summary of
internal study results
so some of the questions that you can
ask yourself here
what is the positive predictive value
and negative predicted value in your
target population and then secondary to
that or is what is the clinical utility
of the targeted genes on your panel so
the panel that that you selected why are
you testing for the genes that you're
testing for are they present in certain
um guidelines as you know you want to
test these specific genes and these
tumor types for all of your samples so
just a summary of the guidelines and the
literature for all of the genes on your
panel um is is an approach that i've
seen some labs take to address this
clinical performance characteristics
section there
so you know on layered on top of that
for a good number of sites that we work
with both in the u.s and then starting
to see globally labs wanting to
incorporate these experiments as well
are the new york state level approaches
and
um they have uh you know in addition to
what i just went through for the college
of american pathologist guidelines new
york state has a few
different you know experiments and
approaches that they like to see for
analytical validation so the main one is
this analytical accuracy
this is not a huge experiment it's
actually pretty straightforward to
include it in most validations and we
found it to be a really informative
experiment to do as one of our first
experiments in in most av engagements
that we go through and what that is is
it's when you sequence uh new york state
wants to see you know two well
characterized reference samples so like
na12878 or na19240
those are generally what we
recommend labs will run through as part
of these experiments because they're
easy to procure they're really high
quality dna you can get them as
extracted material and they're not very
expensive
so you know all of those things make
them really good candidates for that in
addition to that they're extensively
characterized by a number of different
labs and there's nice publicly available
databases so if you detect a variant on
your panel um or when you detect
variants on your panel for these two
samples you can actually go into those
databases and see are those
expected to be there i.e true positive
or are they not expected to be there or
fault are they false positives
and what you want to do with those tam
samples is determine a robust laboratory
specific error rate across all the areas
targeted by your assay and new york
state wants to see that error rate of
less than two percent
and generally labs don't have too many
issues of achieving um that you know air
rate specification outlined by the new
york state guidelines and so again
that's just a really nice
first level experiment to start to get
into your av
um and and then on new york state has um
a component that they call initial
validation and it's actually very very
similar to
the the cap accuracy section so for new
york state the initial validation
what they call out is you must include a
minimum of 50 patient samples in your
initial validation and you want those
samples to comprise specimens of all
intended sample and tumor types
if ffpe is going to be included in how
you're offering the test then you do
want to have a representative number of
samples should be derived from ffpe they
don't give an a specific number of those
50
but you know you want as many of that 50
as possible to be ffpe if not all 50.
you know they do specify that
circulating tumor dna assays or liquid
biopsy assays they must meet that
requirement independently so 50 ct dna
samples for the initial validation so if
you have a panel that you can actually
use the same panel for an sfpe sample as
well as a liquid biopsy sample new york
state wants to see 50 ffpes and 50
circulating tumor dna or total nucleic
acid samples
run through as part of the validation
work
some more details around that those 50
samples must contain all the variant
types reported by the assay so that
would be smv
indel cnvs fusions what have you
and all of the variants in that initial
validation they must be confirmed by an
orthogonal method um so for the variance
you detect as part of your validation
you can reflex those to like sanger
sequencing qpcr or fish and you can
actually do that in the same lab so if
you have those panels up and running
already you can just reflex your
samples that you detected those variants
via ngs reflex them to the orthogonal
methodology in-house
you can also
confirm those variants using next
generation sequencing if it's done on a
different platform you can actually do
that in the same lab if it's going to be
run on the same platform or using the
same chemistry you can actually do that
but it needs to be done in a different
clio laboratory here in
clia in the u.s but um generally in a
sort of a regulated laboratory
and so for customers that you know we've
worked with
you know we've done a number of
different strategies here to to get
these confirmations um i've seen labs do
sample exchanges with one another um to
help each other get validated and then
we also actually have a service for our
av customers where we can actually
generate orthogonal ngs data in a clia
laboratory
as well to supplement the validation
data that's an add-on service for our
our av customers
that's available to them that you know
people have found helpful as well
so that's the new york state initial
validation they also have some
additional language around the
sensitivity studies i i did talk a
little bit about sensitivity studies for
for cap because they're required for cap
they're also required for new york state
department of health so if a particular
lab falls under both you'd want your
analytical sensitivity studies to
incorporate these uh additional layers
of detail but they're just technically
good things to keep in mind and try to
do globally as well because they're not
too much additional runs but they
actually they do make a lot of sense in
terms of how you should probably be
thinking about designing your
sensitivity studies
um so what they say is you know of
course you want to establish that
sensitivity for each type of variant
detected by the panel
but you also want to do that at the
lower limit of nucleic acid input that's
i think a key distinction that they call
out specifically that i don't think cap
really does and that's
you know if you say that you're going to
run a 10 nanogram input which is what a
lot of our panels are a 10 nanogram per
pool input you want to do your
sensitivity studies at 10 nanogram input
you know moving forward and you know new
york state also says you can initially
establish these with
mixtures of cell line dna so that's
where you would take a positive cell
line dna for each of the variants like a
k-ras g12c or something you know that's
just an example of snv
you would take that mutation positive
sample and then you dilute that down in
the background of some wild type dna to
bring the allelic fraction down to where
you think your lod is going to start to
be established or limit of detection so
for a solid tumor application it would
be that you know five four to five
percent allele frequency
for a liquid biopsy if you're using that
type of sample you bring that down even
further to that 0.5 or 0.25 percent
alveolic fraction and run your
sensitivity studies that way where you
you run those dilution series through
your panel and evaluate the ability of
your test to detect the variant that you
know is there at each input level
new york state does call out though that
you need to if you're using cell lines
you need to verify those results with
three to five
patient samples that are kind of right
around that um you know allelic fraction
uh lod that you're looking to establish
and so building off of those inputs you
really do need to establish both the
lowest input amount of dna and rna that
still gives reliable results and the
lowest variant allele fraction or vaf
that can reliably be detected at that
amount of input rna or dna
so um you know usually in our experience
moving over towards the right side of
this slide um for ffpe uh applications
we generally had you know good success
in using cell lines to establish those
limits of detection and then reflexing
to ffpe confirmation of them
but then on the you know peripheral
blood or bone marrow
application so a myeloid
type of application or the liquid biopsy
that uses plasma or something like that
depending on sample quality you can use
either cell lines or that primary sample
to establish that really just depends on
the quality of the the quality of the
extracted material that you have on hand
as well as the quantity you need just
practically you need enough material to
be able to dilute them the variance down
to those lower limits of detection
so just as it with ffte if you decide to
use cell lines to establish the
analytical sensitivity then you'll want
to do
confirmation with three to five patient
samples using the intended sample type
to either peripheral blood or bone
marrow or plasma or what have you
so um you know continuing on with the
guidelines new york state does have a
few additional caveats with
precision and reproducibility so this is
again getting into if you have the same
sample and you run it over and over
again making sure that you get the same
variant level results both within a
batch so within run precision or across
batch setups and operators
so a cross run precision so within the
run new york state wants to see a
minimum of three positive patient
samples
per variant class so three snvs three
indels
three cnbs if your panel covers that and
three
fusions as well analyze those in
triplicate on the same run
so that's within run precision and then
reproducibility very similar but just
slightly different numbers
so they want to see four to five
positive patient samples analyzed across
about four to five separate runs here
you want to use different bar codes and
you want to take those samples from the
original dna or rna extracts all the way
through sequencing and data analysis
and you want to do that on different
days
by two different technologists and two
different sequencers and those last two
i think are if possible some labs don't
have multiple operators and then
certainly some labs don't have multiple
sequencers that they're validating so
you you do have you know the
flexibility if that's the right term to
adapt this to your needs and still be
you know falling within what new york
state is looking for
and then the bullet points below this
just talk a little bit about the sort of
acceptance criteria for each of the
different variant classes so for snbs
and indels they want to see 20
replicates each with overall 95 percent
reproducibility
for structural variants or fusions you'd
want to have three of the positive
intended sample types with different
fusion partners so alk red and ross
or something like that so just three
different genes involved in those
fusions
for cnb
three of the positive intended sample
types again for cnv
you'd want those to be in different
genes and evaluate both gains and losses
in these reproducibility studies and
then finally
msi and tmb for msi
3d mss and 3 msi high and tmb kind of a
tmb low intermediate and high value
and critically
across the bottom banner
you want to perform all these studies at
the lower limit of nucleic acid input so
if that's a 10 nanogram input or 20
nanogram input what's the lowest
nucleic acid input that you're
validating and then you also want to do
these studies at on the lower end of
variant allele frequency so if you
establish your limit of detection for
snvs and indels at five percent allelic
fraction then you want to try to have
samples that are kind of near that lod
range to do these precision studies
because you really want to evaluate the
overall precision and reproducibility of
your panel at those lower limits of
detection and input
so
the nice thing about new york state is
that they have kind of a two a two
phase approach they have an initial
validation and then a full validation so
labs need to go through this initial
validation then they can go into
production testing while simultaneously
rolling their validation to get a quote
unquote full validation and so for a
full validation
what you do is
you
do your testing and then for reported
variants with clinical significance that
you detect
in regions that haven't been fully
validated yet which a definition of a
full validation is on the right here for
each variant class
you need to actually confirm those
variants before you can
go ahead and report them out so i won't
run through each of the different
variant classes here but each variant
class has a certain number of
variants that you need to confirm and
then once you finish confirmations of
that number of variants you don't need
to do confirmations anymore that you
know region or that cloud variant class
is fully validated
so moving into then some example data
sets from analytical validation
engagements
that we've done in the past we just
wanted to give some some data and show a
little bit about how how we actually go
about analyzing this data for our
customers so what i'm showing here is an
example of an analytical accuracy study
for one of our new york state labs and
so the two tables on this slide actually
show the results of those experiments
the table on the left shows
the variant level data for na12878
and
na18507 and
na19240 so each column is a different
one of those
genome in a bottle or corial well
characterized samples
and so we had the lab run each of those
samples through this was a myeloid panel
and then we evaluated the variant level
results for each of those
samples
and
for each of the variants targeted by the
panel of which there were 982 for this
application this is a somatic
myeloid type of a panel
so it's not expected that these samples
have any of the mutations targeted by
that panel and sure enough we didn't
detect any mutations every
every position targeted by the panel was
wild type so overall there was 982 and
then we break it down by variant class
as you know required so we had indels
snv and mnb it's broken down here as
well and then overall then we calculate
from those values a negative predictive
value specificity and reproducibility um
kind of study was done on these as well
for those
three different genome and a bottle
samples at the variant level and you can
see that the results look really good
here there were no
false positives detected in the sample
set
the second type of analysis we do on
these is we actually evaluate um
something called the fred quality scores
across the entire target region for the
targeted amplicons on your panel
and the fred quality score is actually a
measure of
you know error rates and sequencing
and thus overall analytical base calling
accuracy and so what we do here is we
take uh the same
data set from those samples and instead
of looking at the you know specific
base pairs that are just targeted by the
panel
we actually look at every base in every
amplicon and say on average what was the
base calling quality
and accuracy across the target region
for those samples what was the lowest
value we saw what was the highest value
we saw and then on average what was the
value that we saw in those samples so
overall analytical accuracy across the
entire target region then
for the sample was 99.3
for this myeloid panel uh on the low end
on the high
99.7 on average 99.6
so we do take that two-prong approach
look at variance and then look across
the entire target region and evaluate
analytical accuracy in both ways
so um moving into uh you know variant
calling accuracy one of the first things
we like to do as i mentioned is run
through
high quality samples on on the first
lane our first chip's worth of of data
and controls
can be really helpful in that regard
control materials can be really helpful
because they increase the number of
overall variants to assess
and we actually have av master controls
that will provide for our customers and
they're actually custom designed for use
with for a variety of
somatic mutation assays with key
variants included and the table on the
right here is just an example a data
table from one of our myeloid analytical
validations where it shows
a subset of the genes that are included
in that control so the first one is uh
you know abl 1
p t315i kinase domain resistance
mutation we know the expected allele
frequency that that variant is in the
control
at and then over here the second two
columns is the observed depth of
coverage and the observed allele
frequency um as detected in that
particular
library preparation and so we do that
for every expected variant uh in that av
master control and then overall then we
can calculate the variant calling
accuracy um by virtue of taking a look
at what we expect should be there and
comparing to that with what was actually
detected in that particular av run
um
on top of that for our avs you know we
we do run uh our customers through the
av with intended sample types so here's
another analytical validation data
example
for a myeloid panel and this is with
peripheral blood and bone marrow samples
and
this was 37 intended sample types that
we ran for for the analytical validation
all 37 of these samples had been
pre-characterized in an external clia
laboratory so we knew the variant level
results on these samples then the site
that was validating was able to run all
37 of them and then we evaluated those
variants compared to what we expected to
be there and from that
broke that down by variant class and
we're able to calculate overall
positive percent agreement and positive
predictive value for each variant level
here so these tables are just to give a
flavor they're probably on the little
the smaller end but to give a little bit
of a flavor of what that analysis looks
like you know for example there were 29
true positive single nucleotide variance
ranging an allelic fraction in this
sample set from 3.7
up to 88.9 with an average allele
frequency of 37.3
some summary statistics around depth of
coverage um for all the variant calls
and then ppa and ppv values and we do
that for every variant class covered by
the panel
and then finally
limits of detection and precision so
again limits of detection or analytical
sensitivity
is you want to see at lower
levels of input and lower
levels of allele frequency or you know
fusion fraction
what what's our variant calling
capabilities at those different levels
so
this is another example data set and
these are actually using our av master
controls to use those for sensitivity
studies so on the left is a summary
table of the dna side so you can see we
have
uh expected vaf range or vary in a
little fraction range and our av master
controls so for variants greater than 10
we break it down between uh variance
between 5 and 10 and then less than 5
um we then evaluate the overall
sensitivity as measured by positive uh
percent agreement at each of those bins
of allele frequency to get an analytical
sensitivity um in this case you know lod
95 or 95 sensitivity at 5 allele
frequency for this particular validation
on the dna side and then on the rna side
very similar approach where we take the
fusion positive samples and then dilute
them in the background of wild type rna
to bring the fusion input levels lower
and lower
and then evaluate the assay's ability to
detect those fusions at the lower input
levels
and
break it down again by input level and
then look at you know of the expected
variance in that lower level um
dilution uh how many of them were
detected versus not detected and so on
and so forth so that's a limits of
detection study
and then finally
precision and reproducibility
so again that gets into taking
those positive intended sample types
running them in triplicate on the same
run day system and operator or across
days and operators if possible
in evaluating am i getting the same
variance detected and here's an example
table of of what that looks like when
it's all said and done so on the top is
the within run precision again as always
we break it apart by variant class
and um then look across all the variants
we know that should be there how many of
them did we detect
were there any false positives that we
saw in the data set were there any
variants that we did not detect but we
expected them to those would be your
false negatives of course and then from
that overall calculate a repeatability
for each variant class
here you'll see a new variant classes
again with a myeloid application so we
separated out
flip 3 internal tandem duplications by
their own
bin here just for increased visibility
to that specific type of variant class
and then a similar approach for
reproducibility
from just across days instead of within
a run
and then the final slide in terms of
data that i have is another
type of reproducibility study that we
did for a customer uh
where whereby they had actually a number
of different ion chefs um
as well as s5 and they were using their
ion chefs to prepare libraries and so we
wanted to make sure that if they
prepared a library on ion chef a
versus ion chef b that they're getting
the same assay performance both at the
you know sequencing metrics level as
well as at the variant level detail as
well and so we designed their av to
incorporate all of that and so on the
table on the left just shows um in their
av summary uh how you know what that
table looked like in terms of here's all
the different um processes that we
evaluated the library preparation
template preparation and then sequencing
and then what chef was used for each of
them and then the serial number of that
chef and then what sample set was used
and in this particular case
we actually did some unique pooling
strategies to increase the total number
of variants as well as bring the varian
allele frequency down on a number of
these to be a little bit closer to
the limits of detection that we were
going for so it was a way for us to do
kind of multiple things and be efficient
in terms of how we're playing the av
design because you know these you know
reagents aren't cheap the
amount of time that it takes to validate
is is considerable and so anything that
we can do to make it the most efficient
as possible is always a good thing
and so with that um i just want to you
know finish finish out by saying you
know when going through the analytical
validation
process it's really important to look at
what are the regulatory
bodies that my lab falls into is it clea
is it cap am i a new york state lab and
then you want to look at the av
requirements for each of those and
design an av strategy that really
satisfies all of your regulatory needs
in a single av
really focus on validating to the most
stringent guideline and usually things
then will fall into place there
so with that i'll pass it to raphael
yes thank you john um
thanks a lot for going to that in-depth
um look into all that it takes to build
um all the the design of the analytical
validation there is that that big aspect
of what are the regulations and um how
do we put this from a from a valid
scientific perspective make it
sensitively sound um to build another
convolution plan um but but it
definitely takes more right than just
that
scientific approach um so so that's what
i want to concentrate on this um next
portion of the of this uh conversation
is um
what else it takes to put all of this
together from the perspective of a um
laboratory on boarding these new panels
and assays what are the challenges that
need to be taken in consideration when
um
doing days successfully
and we'll talk a little bit about the
approach that we take as say as a team
within professional services um in term
of fusion scientific to assist our
customers um with these challenges
so um
the dynamic of elevation uh what it is
uh and just taking it back to the basics
is the use of analytical technique uh
process uh procedures uh to develop and
produce results in documentation form
and this is very critical that aspect of
documenting everything um and collecting
that tangible evidence
to assure that all parts within this cup
of workflow are suitable for the
intended use so
those are very key aspects um
we looked at this um
as what it is an industry uh accepted
process um ultimately we want to prove
that the workflow that is being
implemented um and the procedures being
followed um are suitable for the
intended use
so when we are reporting on this um we
definitely have a good um solid base um
and again scientifically sound to to do
so
when we look at um
onboarding new panels then is that
requires evaluation um but if we have a
major change within that that workflow
that also calls for um
reviewing that it can be a full
revaluation
or it can be something in the
it's similar to a bridge study
so that needs to be
looked at by the
laboratory
management team but we as consultants we
work with our customers and make
recommendations on
what can be done so when we look at
performing an analytical validation
it's definitely required at the time
that that a panel is being um onboarded
um but besides that it's always very
important for the laboratories to keep
in mind if there is a major change in
the workflow if the uh tissues or tar or
targets that are being tested um change
uh to properly address um your your
patient's needs um
that requires take another look at that
workflow and um revalidate so uh
different aspects is not a one-time
thing that needs to be done um it's
always important to keep that eye on if
anything changes we need to we might
need to um re-evaluate it to some extent
so
it does take um
quite a bit to put together a evaluation
and we have seen
all the requirements that are contained
within um the guidelines um but there's
a larger challenge and it is how to put
all of this uh together so there is the
planning there is the uh the design of
what instrumentation we are going to use
um we get the proper training so this
task is a proficient in running these
workflows
there is a design of the validation runs
we saw and the number of parameters that
need to be taken in consideration so
those designs
are definitely key and critical to be
efficient when putting together
analytical validation plan
making sure we have the right materials
um do we have the right uh control mix
to to address um the metrics that we're
looking uh to document um
once we collect the data we need to go
through that
data analysis and get the bioinformatics
support
and then finally make sure we have a
good solid set of documents right that
documents the validation plan document
salty procedures
the results from the data analysis um
all of this
are critical aspects of
putting together an ethical validation
successfully
and definitely to be taken in
consideration so what we
hear from our
customers a little bit of sharing our
experiences is um
for those laboratories that that may not
have as much experience
at the same time they may be experienced
but
they are running multiple projects and
that's very
common within a well-established
laboratory having different priorities
and projects running at the same time
it can be a a big task it can take six
eight up to twelve months uh to complete
this and that's a very critical aspect
that we look when we want to support
our customers and and the laboratories
themselves look at
how quickly they need to onboard a panel
um it is very important to understand
these are all critical aspects within um
analytical validation
so what we
set out to do is uh put together a uh
good solid uh cost-effective
solution um
it's of course it's based on on this ngs
assays uh for this particular service we
don't offer this um to other um
platforms as uh qpcr we offer the same
type of service
but ultimately we're looking at
following the industry quality standards
and regulatory guidelines um that is
very critical for us um and this that
that takes me to what is the the pillars
of our service um and i think that
beyond just being the pillars of of our
service um it is very important for
every um laboratory to look at
what they are what is their mission
ultimately
on boarding these panels as quickly as
possible
to then be able to to serve their
patients
so
the time that it takes to onboard
this panel
that ties to um the profitability of a
of a laboratory right um and and
fulfilling their their mission um
laboratories want to be
that laboratory of choice um they want
to be able
to offer their services and be that
go-to
laboratory so
they again satisfy that that internal
mission um when we look at the cost of
what it takes to
to complete an analytical validation
there are some hard costs um there is
all the reagents all the materials or
the uh controls um that need to be uh
on time that needs to be accessible in
the laboratory uh to go through this um
as quickly as possible um but there is
also all the support that is needed
right so
we look at this from that more
holistic uh perspective of everything
that it takes to complete an energy
consolidation
but ultimately
there is a compliance perspective and
for us that's of ultimate
importance applying the requirements
specifically now to uh molecular assays
um knowing the lab or the documentation
the laboratory needs to have in place um
that really guides when we put together
our analytical validation consulting
engagements um and and those are the
critical aspects that every laboratory
needs to be um looking at uh
to make sure that that again they are
successful on engaging on an av
so
the the four primary components um that
distinguish um now when we look at uh
professional services within thermo
fishing scientific um delivering
our av consulting service
we are very transparent on the way that
we deliver this to customers
when we
uh collaborate in data analysis when we
do the recommendations for the design of
the the runs
all of this is in conjunction with
the laboratory management staff so
[Music]
all the whole design
is in alignment with
that laboratory successfully completing
analytical validation
as a manufacturer of record
we do have access to all of our
development team
we have access to our
field service
engineers our
application consultants
so
all of us we come together as that
integrated solution
when guiding laboratories through
something as challenging as analytical
validation
but we're very flexible
we look at all the different
requirements that need to
be met in order to be successful
but those can vary
by geographical region
different countries will have different
guidelines we went to very very much
detail of
clia new york state cap requirements uh
primarily for north america
and we see this being used as guidelines
outside of north america um but we also
have iso 15
189 and we have different quality
guidelines um
but being that the principles are all
the same
we can definitely adapt relatively easy
and quickly uh to satisfy those needs um
from a technical acumen perspective
we have a very solid team of uh project
managers um
john being one of our uh lead uh project
managers um
with experience within thurman and
outside of thermo um so that comes
together and we are world very close
together um sharing best practices um
and that really gives us um that very
solid base and technical
[Music]
expertise
for this ngs base panels
to do this successfully
so
critical
when we look at uh again uh
implementing um and going through
analytical um validation um
we see three very specific um uh key
people and talents that need to be a
part of that process
one of them is a project manager
because there are many many moving parts
and if we recall um all the different
aspects and and milestones that need to
be accomplished uh through evaluation um
having that key person that manages the
whole process
but at the same time
they are very well experienced with um
completing analytical validation it is
very critical and really really adds
value
to the process
when we look at all the data that is
generated
they're very very big
data sets that are generated not only
for the number of runs but also for
everything all the parameters are we're
looking at um to to measure and report
um so having that expert on
bioinformatics
is also something that is very critical
as part of that
av
team
and finally the application sciences
those
resources
there are experts on the workflow that
can run and and really make
very solid recommendations
on the best practices from a web lab
perspective
so do we have uh from a laboratory
perspective
uh do they have in place all these
different uh people and they are
accessible um to successfully complete a
validation um that's something that
before
going into this
should be determined and and taken in
consideration
um
so
what we look for on this slide it is
very high level perspective of um
the faster um a laboratory can onboard a
panel
the faster they get into that routine
analysis and that's very critical uh for
their mission um and in those cases
where there is a an aspect of the
profitability of the laboratory um again
the faster they get to that point um the
the the faster they get to a return
investment um if that's a a
consideration for the
for the laboratory
so there are many um a
number of deliverables that we include
with our
analytical validation
um project manager is is a key
individual that we include that is part
of our service
that's the person that really guides
the process
we have
our
application scientists
they're also part of our um solution
working hand-in-hand
with the customer on the field um in the
laboratory making sure that all their
questions are answered and again they're
proficient in running through the um
workflow um
when we start generating the data um
again that's another big part of this we
include that technical review uh with
guidance around the uh the metrics and
the data analysis um
in terms of documentation uh we
mentioned that as well as something
that's critical
within analytical validation um we
provide templates for the validation
plan
the
protocol templates
but we also include the samples
in most cases
as well as controls and again
that aspect of the controls um is very
critical because we have predetermined a
number of uh master mix um that can be
used for the different assets and panels
so that really really helps in
addressing very specifically those
performance metrics and finally the
final validation report
once we
do all the analysis
we can
share that with the laboratory along
with the
final report um template uh to document
um again all of the uh data and and the
design of the
analytical
validation
so um
in terms of how we actually uh deliver
this uh john i think you can probably uh
go through this um better than than
anybody at least better than me
um on how we engage with the customers
and how
a successful validation can be can be
run
for sure thanks raphael yeah so you know
everything starts with you know the av
order and
being received the first thing then that
we do after that is fill out and
complete this customer service agreement
with some information that we'll collect
from our customers like an address and
some basic demographics like that
what we then do next is on the thermo
fisher side we actually hold an internal
kickoff call with your av team and your
wider support team along with your your
sales representative
and that allows us all to get aligned
on the process moving forward and we
actually put together
an av checklist that outlines here's all
the reagents that we'll need here's all
the different software things that we'll
have to have in place to get the
validation underway so it's really
starting to get that formalized and
organized process going uh in that
internal kickoff call once we've got
that in place then we go through and do
you know a customer facing kickoff call
where we talk about the av the process
the timelines and review that av
checklist and then we'll also set up a
weekly av meeting um for for moving
forward so for every av that that we do
we have a weekly time set aside and
blocked out and we work around our
customers schedules to make sure that it
suits their schedule and that me and
during that meeting each week we'll talk
about um you know the runs that are
happening that week the data from the
previous week and then you know where
are we in terms of the av how much
longer do we have until we're done and
and that's done on a weekly basis
so once we've got that kickoff call
installation and lab readiness
can happen that's where the instrument
gets installed if it's not already and
qualified um the customer completes the
av checklist and then we'll ship out the
controls for your av as well
once all that's um on site along with
the reagents uh training can be
commenced training is performed by our
field application scientists or clinical
applications consultants
and that helps the lab you know
feel confident in the testing and we
generally have
controls be used for that training and
that training run it can actually be
used for av data as well
um because you know it's known and
pre-characterized samples we generally
have everybody run
you know you know very important samples
for the av but ones that are well
characterized and importantly we can get
more very easily if we need to if
something doesn't go right during
training um but that does increase the
efficiency and reduce overall cost by
incorporating that data into the av
summary as well and then finally once uh
you know the av runs and then are
carried out by by the lab the runs are
completed by the lab personnel and we
support remotely the av team does as
well as the wider thermo-fisher team
team
we have those weekly calls that i
mentioned and
once the av runs are done we then finish
analyzing the data and write the report
that encompasses all of the runs that
were carried out and then review that
report in detail with the team and then
um the av is complete
okay
great
so um
we have talked a lot about
flexibility
um an adaptation and i'll keep this at a
higher level um we have different levels
of service um but they're really
targeted to um different situations um
when we look at a
laboratory that they're just
not necessarily having a compliance
mandate um but they do from a quality
perspective they do want to look at um
and and make a good review and document
documents um how they're performing in
uh running through these assays we'll
have what we call the analytical
performance verification service um
it is a very comprehensive but it is
pre-validation it doesn't include all
the different uh metrics and
documentation that we have discussed uh
so far um this is also a very good tool
for
those instances where they need to do a
bridge study right
so the
the level of
data sets that we want to run
there is definitely nowhere near um
the validation plan is not as as
comprehensive um so this is a very good
solution for that um situation where we
just want to do a pre-evaluation um
check um and and or um a bridge study uh
once a an assay has been
validated
the second level of service we call it
the aeronautical validation regional um
this
looks at a three-year cap new york state
um
validation guidelines um as well as the
iso 5189
for um international requirements
um
but it's not a stringent right so when
we look at the the at the beginning of
this uh talk um the number of runs all
the performance metrics that we want to
run so this will allow us to um very
much customize to each particular
customer
needs and requirements
on how they need to achieve
or complete that
validation
and finally the article validation
service that's the most
comprehensive it very much looks to
the requirements contained within the
cap clia
new york state requirements
clssi is another
higher level more stringent
guideline
that we look at right so that's very
comprehensive um that's the most um
stringent um
unrecognizable service that we
provide but within them um that's that's
the uh it does give us a lot of
flexibility uh to address this customer
needs
um so and to wrap up our um uh this part
of the of the conversation um
the benefits of of
this
approach and from the experience of
working with different customers it
helps accelerate um the launch time how
quickly we onboard um a panel um helps
reduce the uh because um
and the way that we approach this it
adds a lot of transparency into the uh
process uh we are
consultants but we are part of that um
analytical validation team um
collaborating with our um expertise and
and the various um experts that we have
within the team um and ultimately
facilitates lab compliance um with all
that that is inclusive within our
service um we definitely facilitate um
that lab compliance for our uh customers
and that brings to the end of uh the
talk um
we'll keep the references here um
for all the uh different guidelines that
we look at um and scientific papers that
we use for the develop of our service so
that will stay as a as a reference
but that really brings us to the end of
the
conversation here and we'll open now for
uh questions i understand
well thank you john and raphael for that
very informative presentation
i've been monitoring the chat and we've
received some great questions already
so here's the first question that came
into the chat
it says please explain your validation
strategy in terms of meeting regulatory
guidelines
what guidelines do you use to ensure the
laboratory is successful in their
validation
yeah that's a great question so
generally the first thing that i like to
do is have a conversation with the lab
about what regulatory agencies or
guidelines that they might fall into um
just so that i have an understanding and
and can make sure that the av approach
that that we put together is is suitable
for the specifics around the lab that
we're working with now that being said
our general av approaches we like to
follow cap in new york state around the
av design for each of those specific
experiments what we found
globally is that
the av strategies are pretty consistent
across agencies for things like
analytical sensitivity variant calling
accuracy and precision so using that
core framework of cap in new york state
generally works very well for a number
of different regulatory bodies and
raphael i'm not sure if you have
anything else that you'd like to add
there
um no i mean that's pretty comprehensive
right and that has been our experience
so far
um and just just to highlight um we do
have um
engagements uh throughout uh europe
latin america
asia um so we have already had that
experience of looking at the highest
stringency of requirements um and
adapting that to the various
regional requirements and quality
guidelines
okay great well thank you john raphael
for that one
i see another question that came into
the chat what controls do you use in the
validation and how do you ensure that
these are relevant for the validation
yeah that's another another great
question and one that comes up often
for our validation work that we that we
generally do we actually have a custom
set of controls we call them our av
master controls that we actually put
together
based off of
key mutations that a lot of our labs
have been looking for and we've put them
together such that they work with a
number of different uh panels and so
that's generally the main control set
that that we like to use for our
analytical validations it has those key
variants and then on top of that it has
those key variants at
different allelic fractions or copy
numbers so they can actually be really
useful for both general variant calling
accuracy am i detecting the mutations
that i should be detecting as well as
some sensitivity work am i able to
detect them at those low allele
frequency or copy number or fusion
fractions or what have you so generally
we focus around those av av master
controls for our engagements
okay great
um what looks like that's all the time
we have for questions today but i do see
a couple other in the chat so just as a
reminder to our audience for any
questions we didn't have to time the
time to get to today um and for any of
those are submitted as we run this um
this webinar for the on-demand period um
those will all be addressed by the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
so in closing i i want to thank again
our speakers john williamson and rafael
ramirez and to everyone who participated
in this presentation
we hope you enjoy the rest of the event
and be sure to check back frequently for
new content and presentations added
throughout the year
you